it's hard to be a mad scientist but even
harder to create an animated series
that's beloved by millions of fans
around the world we're taking a portal
to the universe behind Rick and Morty to
discover little-known facts about the
show strap in
while the pop-culture references on Rick
and Morty abound so do allusions to the
voice actors most famous roles actor and
comedian David Cross plays an alien who
can't handle nudity almost as if he's a
never-nude
like his character Tobias on Arrested
Development I'm sorry no I need you to
be completely undressed
I am completely undressed then there's
snowball a cute dog who wants to take
over the world and is assisted by an
accountant there played by rob paulsen
and maurice lamarche the actors who
voiced the title roles on Pinky and the
brain a show about two lab mice with
designs on world domination actress
Sarah Chalke voices beth smith Rick's
daughter and Morty's mother Beth is a
horse surgeon which makes Rick and Morty
the third time Chuck has played a blond
doctor on TV following her years on
scrubs and a recurring role on How I Met
Your Mother as part of the promotional
blitz for the 1998 Disney movie Mulan
McDonald's briefly offered a Szechuan
dipping sauce for its chicken McNuggets
in 2017 and the Rick and Morty season 3
premiere Rick Rance that getting more of
that sauce is essentially his reason for
living that's my series our world for
six night seasons consequently the
reference inspired a frenzied response
from Rick and Morty fans leading to
petitions at change.org to persuade
McDonald's to bring back Szechuan sauce
leading up to the premiere of the third
season if Rick and Morty
McDonald's came through the company
posted a picture of three giant jugs of
Szechuan sauce on its Facebook page
along with an announcement that it would
be giving them all away in addition to
some lucky fans one other person got a
very special delivery of the sauce Rick
and Morty's own Justin roiland he
tweeted out a photo of his newly
acquired stash along with a personal
letter from McDonald's the point of the
TV shows writers room is to brainstorm
ideas work them out
turn them into usable stories that's how
Rick and Morty riders got the Nugget for
pickle Rick the famous episode in which
Rick turns himself into a pickle and has
to grapple with all kinds of challenges
to get to a family therapy appointment
co creator Dan Harmon told Fast Company
I think it was a case of somebody just
saying what if we started the episode
this way with him turning himself into a
pickle but why Harmon says it's because
Rick is his own worst enemy and he'd
want to prove himself
stop digging for hidden layers and just
be impressed I'm a pickle I'm just
trying to figure out why you would do
this
that's when Harmon and the staff
realized they could find inspiration
from a second season episode of Breaking
Bad in which Walt and Jesse's Winnebago
breaks down in the desert Harmon
explained we get to see Walter White up
against primal forces instead of
watching him negotiated bluff with
street dealers and kingpins it was
interesting to watch him trapped in a
hot band about to die and having to fall
back on his basic science knowledge
similarly Rick has all sorts of tech at
his disposal but he can rely only on his
wits to endure life as a pickle
each episode of Rick and Morty begins
with one of the most recognizable
opening sequences in modern television
as the camera soars through space and
then transitions into scenes of Rick and
Morty and their family avoiding all
sorts of dangers it's company by a
haunting electronic score driven by what
sounds like synthesizers and a theremin
a classic sci-fi combo
I heard sci-fi noises did you make a
breakthrough those elements sound
familiar but so does the final product
which might be because Rick and Morty
composer Ryan elder pulled from three
famous sci-fi theme songs in particular
although it wasn't actually written for
this show Elder explained that main
theme was written for another pilot that
Justin roiland and I were working on it
was called dog world and I guess the
elevator pitch would be a planet where
dogs evolved from men but it was more
kid oriented roiland asked elder to come
up with a song that was adventurous not
unlike the themes from invader zim bar
escape and Doctor Who you can't get any
more direct than that so that's just
what elder did he said I kind of put all
those in a blender and came up with
something that I felt had a nice
adventurous build to it a sense of
anticipation and forward momentum when
they later needed a theme song for the
pilot of Rick and Morty elder
that track he'd made for dog world and
suck it in as a temporary fix the rest
is history
and as time went on we just were like
you know what everybody likes it let's
go with this you know I've barely
changed it from one to the other Rick
and Morty is one of Adult Swim's biggest
hits of all time and it inspired a fan
base so devoted it was willing to wage
war against a major fast food chain it's
a successful series by most any metric
and yet it went on an incredibly long
hiatus after the final episode of season
3 aired in October 2017 the first
episode of season four wasn't scheduled
at the air until November 2019 for than
two years later just why and how did it
take co-creators Justin roiland and Dan
Harmon to get more episodes in the can
the simple answer contract negotiations
dragged on according to Justin roiland
in GQ the creator's wanted enough money
so Harman wouldn't quote have to take 12
other jobs while we're working on season
four however the wait appears to have
been well worth it in 2018 Rick and
Morty a show that it only aired 31
episodes at that point was officially
renewed for a fourth season and beyond
landing a huge 70 episode order from
Adult Swim it's not quite forever and
ever but it's a good start
Rick and Morty forever and 400 years
Ricky boys
be in Ricci morning running around and
Rick and Morty time all day long forever
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]